malgré la distance la guerre est dans
toutes les têtes samedi matin une
soixantaine d'habitants s'est rassemblée
devant la mairie de villepreux un moment
de solidarité pour le peuple ukrainien
organisée par la municipalité ce qui se
passe c'est vraiment report on va
seville complètement rayé de la carte
les gens complètement parti sur les
routes moi ça me fait vraiment quelque
chose on est tous concernés et tous très
inquiet par rapport au conflit
aujourd'hui en ukraine et par rapport à
l'invasion du pouvoir politique russe on
est rassemblé pour montrer notre unité
pour montrer notre soutien et notre
solidarité à destination du peuple
ukrainien l'occasion également pour la
commune de lancer une collecte de
produits de secours et d'hygiène car
dans de nombreuses villes des yvelines
la mobilisation est au rendez vous
depuis quelques jours à l'appel de
l'association des maires de france
elle a été rapide notamment à poissy
depuis mercredi c'est plus de deux
tonnes de matériel qui ont été
réceptionnés qui sont ensuite
compartimentée par notre réserve
communale et citoyenne c'est un élan du
coeur a dû l'autre paire appareil c'est
une générosité en lettres majuscules et
et nos amis ukrainiens valent bien ça
évidemment une générosité qui s'opère
dès le plus jeune âge à regarder les
infos y avait des très grosses
explosions ça m'a fait beaucoup fait
mouvement j'avais pris une couverture
un champ dentifrice et enchanteront
malone et des plaids et des prodiges
emma elle a décidé de
de trier de voir ce qui pouvait servir
j'ai vendu les deux montres aux enfants
qui prennent conscience de ce qui se
passe et puis ben voilà on a toutes les
choses à donner donc ya pas de raison
des gardes et à chaque fois les communes
s'appuie sur les associations présentes
dans les yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux la municipalité oeuvre avec
perspective ukrainienne présidée par
unis ni monteyne lors d'une première
collecte organisée en mairie le 4 mars
80 cartons remplis de vêtements chauds
aux sacs de couchage et de nourriture
sont partis pour l'ukraine tous les
vêtements qui sont arrivés tous les
vivres enfin beaucoup de choses qui sont
qui sont arrivés dès en une heure
seulement on voit que c'est déjà plein
plein plein plein de cartons c'est la
protection civile qui va s'en charger de
les acheminer sur la frontière polonaise
malheureusement elle va pas traverser la
frontière et ça va pas être distribué
directement à la population locale mais
pour les réfugiés qui se sont de plus en
plus nombreux sur la pologne roumanie
moldavie tous les vêtements c'est plus
pour des familles qui vont arriver dans
des familles françaises une nouvelle
collecte est prévue dans la ville le 12
mars avec un rassemblement à midi devant
l'hôtel de ville l'association
perspectives ukrainienne recherche aussi
des familles d'accueil pour les
ukrainiens réfugié en france